after several days of camping and long
distance bicycle riding you decide to
ride straight home
riding at a constant rate after two
hours of riding you are 10 kilometers
from home
and after four hours of riding you are
five kilometers from home once you begin
to ride home and how many hours will you
finish your bike ride and arrive at home
this last sentence is a little bit
redundant it's really should you say
what was your total
length of your bike ride home but let's
just think about the data that they gave
us
so let's just think about
in one
act on one column let's put a how long
you've been writing
so time
time writing and then in this column
let's put the distance
distance from home so they tell us that
after two hours and the time is in hours
after two hours we are 10
kilometers from home and after four
hours after four hours we are five
kilometers from home
and we are going to home at a constant
rate so let's think about what this rate
is
when our time increased by two hours
when our time increased by two hours
our distance decreased by five
so if our time increased by another two
hours
if it increased by another two hours so
now six hours have gone by then our
distance will have decreased by five
again so our decrease distance will
decrease by five again and we are zero
kilometers from home
so we've answered our question once you
begin a ride home and how many hours
will you finish your bike ride and
arrive home well it'll take you a total
of a total of six hours now i'm going to
ask ourselves another question that they
didn't ask us here which is what is what
how many how far away was i when i
started riding home well we could back
things up a little bit actually let me
copy and paste all of this
and move it down so let me cut and let
me paste this all down a little bit so
we have some extra space
and let me draw a little white line here
and then finally let me erase
this business right over here
and so we can think of the other way
where were we at time zero where were we
at time zero so time zero that was that
was two hours
two hours before this point right over
here so here we are subtracting two
hours so instead of subtracting five we
will add five they're gonna have
opposite signs so we were 15
kilometers away another way that you
could think about this you can another
way you could think about is we started
we started 15 kilometers away
two hours goes by two hours goes by and
our distance has decreased five
kilometers so let's actually graph this
just to visualize things in graphical
form so let's say that this is our time
axis actually our distance axis distance
in this case is a function of time so
the convention is to plot that on the
vertical axis and then let's put time on
the horizontal axis
so that is time right over there so when
time equals 0 our distance is 15
kilometers so let's see let's see this
is 5
10
15.
so when time is equal to zero distance
is 15 kilometers that's this point right
over here and then when time is equal to
six our distance is zero kilometers
so it's not perfectly so let's say that
this is
this is one hour
two hours
three hours four hours five hours and
six hours obviously should we draw it a
little bit neater than that
let's do it this way let's call this two
four
and six hours obviously not the same
scales for the vertical and horizontal
axis but this last point right over here
when
time is six hours our distance from home
is zero kilometers so that's that point
there and we're traveling at a constant
rate so our line will look like this
our line would look like this now one
question you might ask yourself well can
we quantify this rate or how would this
rate relate to the inclination of this
line well remember the inclination of
this line is defined as slope and that's
the rate of change of our vertical axis
to our horizontal axis so the slope of
this line
is equal to
the change in our vertical axis this
triangle is the greek letter delta
shorthand for change in change in our
vertical axis with respect to a change
in our horizontal axis so in our
horizontal axis we already see it when
our change when we have a change of 2 in
our horizontal axis and we saw that with
the first two points when we went from
when we went from two comma ten that was
this point right over here to four comma
five
to four comma five what was our change
in time
well our change in time
our change in time was we went from two
to four so i could do it right over here
so our change in time was equal to two
and what was our change in distance well
our change in distance we went from ten
to five so our change in distance was
equal to negative five it went down when
our time increased so it's negative five
so the slope of this line is negative
five halves we started at time zero at
fifteen kilometers so actually we can
express the equation for this line we
could write that distance and we could
even write it as distance as a function
of time like that or we could just write
distance
is equal to
we started at 15
15 kilometers 15 kilometers and then we
decrease our distance from there as time
increases so it's 15 plus negative five
halves times time or we could say minus
five over two
five over two
times
time
so we didn't have to do all of this we
could have just reasoned through it with
the table that we did really in the
first minute but it is nice to just
think about this in all the different
ways